neue mineralien entdeckte radioaktives
uran gestein und wurde im red canyon
entdeckt die mineralien haben
außergewöhnliche eigenschaften und
welche da sind jetzt bei pflanzen weg
zum cup spiel kommen mit der überschrift
vom utah rundlauf empfängt vor ort
rhenium beginnt die pressemitteilung der
michigan technological university um die
es heute geht eine forschergruppe hat in
utah einen sogenannten red canyon drei
neue und bis dato noch nie zuvor
gefriert uran gespanne entdeckt levit
leo wieland und red canyon mit wenn drei
außergewöhnlich kristalline und eben
auch radioaktive minerale davon solche
strukturen findet und analysiert weil
besonders wichtig für die forschung
zitat solche minerale lehrern und eine
menge darüber wie uran in der umwelt
vorkommt und verteilt werden kann
erklärt travis toll von der michigan
technological university von diesen
neuen mineralien haben ganz besondere
eigenschaften sie sind zeichnet sich
durch etwa einen millimeter langen
nadeln aus leo wie la witt durch
wasserlöslichkeit und recht kenne mit
durch die welten wachstum
voraussetzungen red canyon mit kann
nämlich nur mit mangan und ammonium
gedeihen faszinierend oder planet
strotzt nur so vor mineralien und wir
können immer und immer wieder neues
entdecken und es ist erstaunlich wie
viel wir davon noch nicht kennen zitat
wir leben auf einen planeten mit
bemerkenswerter mineral vielfalt es gibt
unzählige varianten in farbe und form in
der geochemischen nische oder der
komplexität der kristallstruktur so
beschrieben 1 experten der carnegie
institution in der fachzeitschrift
american männerrolle gibt die grosse
mineral vielfalt hier auf der erde von
den unzähligen varianten kennen wir
heute übrigens rund 5100 experten
verfolgen könnte es aber noch 1500
völlig unbekannte mineralien geben
cognac von der michigan technological
university zufolge weiß aber auch eine
sache ein mineral für entdeckten das
wasser
neu ist eine andere aber ist es alle
erforderlichen analysen durchführen zu
können um von der international water
association die offizielle anerkennung
und einen namen zu bekommen und im
weltall war ja auch bald nach rohstoffen
gesucht werden und vielleicht dann auch
mineralien gefunden werden mehr dazu in
diesem video und hier also auch hier
könnt ihr mir einen tausch von abo- und
nicht vergessen die glocke zu läuten
also bis dann bleibt dran